you don't understand I need this I need
this loan please just leave the four
fleabag was an Emmy Award winning hit TV
show it was a one-act one-woman stage
play Wow
I find my sister outside the lecture
hall she's uptight and beautiful and
probably anorexic my sister she's
uptight and beautiful and probably
anorexic but clothes look awesome on her
birthday
in this video I'm going to examine how
the show evolved on its way from the
stage to the screen this video is
sponsored by mu B check out the new
movie library with your free trial when
you go to MU be calm / Thomas flight
dad's way of coping with two motherless
daughters was to buy us tickets to
feminist lectures stop godmother and
eventually stop calling the general
overarching story of the play is the
same as the first season of the show
thanks for coming in today really
appreciate you sending in your CV thank
you for coming in today we really
appreciate you considering us for your
small business startup loan okay that
wasn't my intention as you are probably
aware we haven't had the opportunity to
support many any women their businesses
since I ran from the station so just a
bit hot so I'm really excited about
important I thank somebody know I don't
know I've actually I ought to be crazy
there's quite a bit more story in the
show because not only does the show run
longer but it's often able to tell the
same amount of story more efficiently i
snort laugh at myself and then catch the
eye of an attractive looking man ah well
he is attractive in holding his paper to
about here it all gets a bit Road and
tea from the nose down but it's good
enough as am I on the tube he smiles at
me with his tiny mouths
I smile back the Chi pulls into
Tottenham Court Road we both stand up at
the same time I could vomit he says to
me which doesn't happen very often does
really well this doesn't happen very
often does it I gave a horribly giggly
this is gonna sound crazy because it
might sound a bit crazy but he's got
this crazy idea and the crazy idea is to
take my number that said there are many
moments in the show that play was almost
the exact same timing as the stage
version kate 9 yeah yeah she's dead now
she's dead now Jack Bentley killed
herself it wasn't her intention but it
wasn't I realized I'm wearing the top
that she lost years ago yes it's gonna
be tense her eyes fixed on it don't take
your coat off
no okay but and I can see her brain
ticking she decides to bank it for later
pacing beads are often preserved even as
aspects of the story are changed do you
want to go I want to ask her to have a
drink with me before she goes but I
don't know how I just watched her Platts
disappear into the crowd outside the
tube text from rodent still smiling
smiley face in general though the pacing
of delivery is slower in the stage
version than in the TV version alright
what's going on okay yeah that's nothing
yeah I don't know it's nothing you know
it's really too cool I didn't even
oh I have a horrible feeling I'm greedy
pathetic cynical centigrade the prey he
just looks at me you get all that from
your mother well
you get all that from your mother good
what a story in the monologue is
expanded on screen visually the fridge
is a new detail but he does always go
the extra mile I mean this is a new
detail he does usually go the extra mile
a few times these even clean the whole
flat like it's a crime scene
I've often considered timing on great
wealth so and the faculty code of it
going over so that we're not just
hearing fleabags perspective but seeing
it as well I think this is where at
times a line or two of exposition
becomes an entire scene basically the
presents and the booze birthday two
years ago I panicked and bought her a
guinea pig she called it Hillary and now
I'm stuck with it two years ago I okay
the most important thing is if you don't
like it we can't take it back okay okay
happy birthday I'm sorry
I panicked but the biggest difference is
that the play operates as a monologue
with a sides of dialogue she tells me
she's finally been offered the wet dream
of a job in Finland where they want to
over pay and under work her she doesn't
have to wear power suits anymore Wow
Finland but she's turning it down
because her husband says she shouldn't
go because of Jake while the show is
scenes of dialogue with a side of
monologue I'm turning it down
what why Martin Martin says it would be
unfair on Jake he's weird probably
clinically but he talks about that these
fourth wall breaking asides are much of
the charm and brilliance of the show
they're what allow Phoebe's performance
to really shine
he used to say things to Mike you can
keep up but in the show much of the
power of these asides comes from their
contrast to the scenes of standard
narrative dialogue whose death hit the
papers local cafe girl gets hit by bike
and a car and another bike and as she
used to work here
Khai eat a water or a sandwich or
something I mean the man's got a problem
speak to me speak to me no one wants to
admit there's a problem because then
they don't get to have crazy nights out
with fun drunk Mountain chicken are you
chicken because the entire play is a
monologue in the stage version you lose
that contrast no one wants to admit
there's a problem because then they
don't get to have crazy nights out with
fun drunk Martin anymore
watching the stage version you lose the
feeling that fleabag is secretly pulling
you aside and telling you her deepest
thoughts while the rest of the world
goes by unaware
I think fleabag is a good stage
performance but a brilliant TV show is a
bit of a love and she turns to me and
she says oh you're such a lovely man
[Music]
but even though I think the show is
better I think the show developing out
of the stage version played a key role
in influencing the show's uniquely
personal and intimate perspective in the
stage version it feels like fleabag is
telling you a story and the show it
feels like we the audience aren't just
being spoken to but are a part of her
world the show expands on the story in a
way that makes fleabag a more vulnerable
and compelling character and is
ultimately able to build on that story
and stylistic foundation to great effect
in season 2 I think the recorded stage
performance is worth checking out if
you're a fan of the show but I must warn
you sadly it lacks Olivia Colman I just
can't stop conjuring an image of you
sitting around that cafe just all alone
feeling so terribly lonely just can't
stop picturing it
thanks to movie for sponsoring this
video movie is an online curated cinema
streaming high-quality art house
independent and international film you
get a new curated film every day but now
Mubi is adding the movie library which
gives you access to a larger back
catalogue of curated films if you
haven't seen it check out Los Angeles
plays itself it's a feature-length video
essay about how Los Angeles is portrayed
in
and it's been influential on a lot of
video essays including myself it's in
the movie library in the US and you can
check it out for free with your free
trial when you go to movie comm slash
Thomas flight thanks so much for
watching this video special thank you to
my patrons I also want to mention that I
now have merch available you can go to
Thomas flight comm slash merch or click
the link in the description to check out
the options